so obviously twitter doesn't exist so we
can share opinions with one another
it exists to silence anyone who
challenges the biden administration and
the oligarchs in silicon valley who
support
the bide administration and to that end
they've censored the former president
the new york post charlie kirk the
babylon beat this show last night
twitter suspended a very popular account
called libs of tick tock now libs of
tick tock is essentially an account that
finds video of liberals talking about
themselves and their own beliefs and
posts it
it was
of course targeted because once you see
what these people are saying
they discredit themselves and horrify
normal people here's some of the footage
libs of tik tok is on earth i want to
talk to the kids sometimes human beings
are more than boy or girl
sometimes we're something else sometimes
we're both
sometimes um we kind of float
in between mostly i feel feminine or
non-binary
today i'm feeling really femme and
cat-like as well
yeah i wouldn't have to hide or lie or
be embarrassed about a natural function
my body does
so all that to say i'm on my period you
heard me having a period for the first
time in six years and not just any
period the period from hell i identify
as a threat a nightmare and a goddess so
please bow down to me i do not believe
in god i don't worship the devil but yes
i am a satanist which means i am my own
god and i worship myself
so for the crime of letting liberals
talk about themselves and showing people
what they actually think media matters
did a hit piece on libs of tick tock
described it as hate
and twitter dutifully pulled it off the
platform that's exactly how that system
works so the creator of libs of tick
tock remains anonymous why because we
live in a country where you can't even
say what you think without
threats of violence against you if
you're not on the left but we are happy
to talk to that person over the phone
which we are doing now the creator of
libs of tick tock joins us
on the line don't know your name glad
you're on um
so you were pulled off twitter
uh after you were attacked by media
matters for disseminating hate were you
surprised by this
exactly no i was not surprised at all it
definitely felt like a very organized
attack by the last to get me suspended
so how big and this is not the first
platform from which you've been
suspended for holding up liberals in
their own voice
to the rest of the country where else
have you been kicked off
i have been kicked off of tick tock and
i've gotten multiple violations on
instagram
it's just remarkable to me in a country
like ours that you feel the need to
remain anonymous tell us why you're not
giving us your name tonight
well i've gotten a few death breaths i
get a ton of hate mail and the left has
been showing recently um you know
how they would treat people who
disagreed with them
um it's funny because there is some of
the difference i mean i've like reported
it and the people they still have their
accounts on twitter so you know you can
threaten violence and still keep your
account but you can't play a video of
what a leftist is themselves saying
right so your opinions are violence
their violence are protected speech
you see how that works
thank you so much for your bravery and
again i just can't overstate you're not
even giving your opinions necessarily
just holding up their opinions for the
country to see and for revealing them in
their natural habitat
you're on the run uh
creator of libs or tiktok whatever your
name is thanks for joining us tonight
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight